jouons et la réponse de frédéric guéry
président de la collectivité européenne
d'alsace qui demande le démembrement du
grand test avant de recevoir jean
rottner deux invités dont 15 minutes où
nous accueillerons le sénateur des
vosges
jean un grès et pour commencer cette
émission nous sommes avec catherine
trautmann bonjour bonjour merci beaucoup
d'être avec nous ce matin vous êtes
ancien maire de la ville de strasbourg
vous êtes actuellement conseillère
municipale vous avez été on s'en
souvient bien sûr ministre de la culture
dans le gouvernement de lionel jospin
pour nous interroger à mes côtés franck
buchy bonjour franck bonjour merci
d'être avec nous journalistes dernières
nouvelles d'alsace
catherine trautmann on commence bien sûr
par la crise sanitaire vous avez sans
doute écouté hier jean castex pas de
confinement pas de nouvelles mesures
coercitives
est-ce que l'exécutif a raison dans sa
stratégie j'ai l'impression que plus le
gouvernement tergiverse et plus les
français se déclarent prêts à un
confinement
parce qu'ils écoutent les scientifiques
et parce qu'ils font preuve de raison et
parce que ils ont besoin de clarté de
prévisibilité et de cohérence c'est ce
qu'ils attendent du gouvernement
c'est ce que parfois le gouvernement ne
démontre pas d'une part dans la
négociation sur les vaccins qui ont été
trop lente pas n'ont pas démarré de
manière collective assez tôt et surtout
le gouvernement a fait confiance à des
entreprises qui n'ont pas répondu
présent que ça nous touche ici parce que
sanofi qui est en train de fermer un
site à strasbourg a n'a pas été capable
de sortir un vaccin
donc on le voit aujourd'hui on attend on
attend de pouvoir retrouver le goût de
l'avenir pour les enfants d'abord parce
que ils commencent à être touchés par le
confinement
le demi confinement où l'incertitude
mais aussi pour les entreprises qui
souffrent de plus en plus pour le
travail
le télétravail ne peut pas être un
asservissement à domicile et donc ce
sont les sujets qui sont aujourd'hui sur
la table et dont les français
souhaiteraient pouvoir parler entre eux
aussi ce qu'ils ne peuvent pas tout à
fait faire au niveau local vous pensez
que la réaction les actions mises en
place par là par la ville ont été les
bonnes je pense que la ville essaye de
s'adapter il ya déjà eu la préparation
du premier confinement une expérience
qui a été concluante je dirais pour la
continuité du service public pour la
prévention
on peut peut-être souhaité d'autres
mesures un accompagnement plus déterminé
et plus important des étudiants par
exemple qui ont besoin d'être soutenus
dans cette période mais je pense que la
ville s'est préparée aussi d'ailleurs un
deuxième confinement au kazoo et a
ouvert les centres de vaccination mais
si le centre de vaccination principal dû
fermer ce n'est pas du fait qu'il sait
parce qu'on manquait de vaccins et je
pense qu'il y a quand même aussi de la
part du gouvernement une manière
d'éviter un reproche
on lui a reproché de confiner parce
qu'elle est pas les masques et
aujourd'hui il veut éviter leurs proches
qu'ils confinerait parce qu'à passer de
vaccins ce qu'on est quand même dans
cette situation va revenir sur la
question des vaccins mais sur ce
confinement est ce que pour vous s'il a
lieu il doit être territorialisée
puisqu'on va ya des inégalités un haut
niveau de l'épidémie entre les régions
et ce qu'il faut forcément un
confinement nationale je pense que tout
confinement qui reprendrait devrait être
territorialisée d'abord pour éviter la
circulation intense du virus
ce qu'il faut éviter c'est de donner la
place à une mutation rapide de ce virus
qui montre sa dangerosité et et le fait
qu'il est de plus en plus contagieux
avec ces mutations et je pense que ce
qui est très important pour moi en tout
cas
quand j'observe les choses c'est que on
doit absolument vacciner les personnes
les plus fragiles celles qui sont une
ode efficient parce que c'est lorsqu'on
a des problème de système immunitaire
qu'on est le plus en difficulté si on
contracte ce virus donc de fait les
mesures barrières restent aujourd'hui
cela nous ferait vacciner ou
personnellement oui vous avez été
ministre de la culture est ce que vous
considérez que le gouvernement actuel
d'ailleurs ce secteur de manière assez
difficile enfin ce que la culture n'est
pas sacrifiée aujourd'hui c'est une
question qui me concerne beaucoup je
pense que la culture dans son ensemble
souffre énormément
que ce soit les créateurs les lieux de
diffusion que ce soit le cinéma le
théâtre tout le spectacle vivant mais on
parle moins des arts plastiques des
artistes peuvent plus exposé je crois
que tout le monde souffre énormément des
mesures ont été prises et il ne faut pas
les négliger
elles ont un permis je dirais de
survivre le problème d'un artiste ou
d'un groupe de musique c'est de pouvoir
accéder au public
donc j'ai vu que le service public
ouvrait une chaîne qui permet d'exposer
et de garder le contact avec le public
je m'en réjouis parce que c'est une
mesure à laquelle je pensais une plus
tôt c'est à dire la possibilité de
continuer d'avoir ce goût la culture est
en même temps un moyen aussi de se
retrouver de se retrouver pour soi et de
se retrouver avec les autres et on a vu
à quel point pendant le premier
confinement les gens aller sur les
réseaux sociaux pour voir des artistes
heureusement un dernier mot sur la
culture roselyne bachelot vous trouvez
qu'elle défend suffisamment le secteur
auquel raisonne plus en tant qu'ancienne
ministre de la santé qu'en tant que
ministre la culture
bon je pense qu'on aurait pu trouver des
dispositions peut être un petit peu plus
souple pour permettre quand même la
présence de la création et de la culture
dans l'aude en eau dans nos villes et
dans nos quartiers elle doit en faire
plus c'est le cas c'est le cas dans
d'autres pays mais je crois aussi que 1
roselyne bachelot n'a pas toujours été
entendus ou n'a pas toujours été prise
en compte et je le regrette parce que on
ne pense pas la place que tient la
culture dans l'économie et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui les effets seront à long
terme puisque les programmations se font
d'une année à l'autre et donc vous
lorsque vous soutenez l'initiative la
ville de strasbourg
d'expérimenter dès l'ouverture de
certains milieux culturels oui je pense
qu'il faut le faire il faut le tenter et
il faut le faire évidemment avec
beaucoup de prudence
mais on a besoin aussi de pouvoir
redonner une perspective
on a vu par exemple que pour les gens
qui travaillaient dans le domaine
culturel
le fait de répéter par exemple n'était
pas considéré au début du conflit du
premier confinement comme un travail
or il travaillait justement ces
personnes et justement va parler sera
durable ou franck alors vous avez été
vice présidente de l'eurométropole en
charge du développement économique et de
l'innovation recrues regrettez-vous
aujourd'hui que l'usiné why wait donc
ses 200 millions d'investissements
perspective de 300 emplois soit installé
aux portes de l'eurométropole non pas
dans la métropole
j'ai personnellement travaillé sur une
possible implantation de cette
entreprise au début sans savoir
d'ailleurs qu'il s'agissait de huawei
sur le territoire du parc d'innovation
illkirch graffenstaden tout était prêt
c'était possible le contexte était
favorable on est prêts d'alcatel on est
dans un espace qui est dédié aussi au
numérique et donc il y avait une
certaine cohérence et je pense que c'est
la raison pour laquelle huawei avait
aussi retenu parmi les sites possibles
celui ci est est-ce que c'est pas un
signal inquiétant d'après vous de la
politique économique de la municipalité
dont vous êtes partenaires
alors je pense qu'il ya toujours il ya
toujours un message quand on accueille
une entreprise
elle vient on à elle vient en alsace il
y avait au départ un choix sur toute la
france donc elle a choisi la france elle
a choisi l'alsace c'est positif mais
évidemment le fait de mettre tellement
de difficultés et de temps à se
déterminer pour dire ce que les deux
collectivités souhaité le fait qu'on est
là l'eurométropole qui était plutôt
favorable la ville moins favorable a
fait que au bout d'un moment
l'entreprise a fait ce que fait toute
entreprise est inquiète pour l'avenir
sur le plan économique je vais vous dire
notre groupe s'est allié à cette
majorité parce que nous avons pris cet
engagement aussi devant les
strasbourgeois
nous serons
vigilant exigeant mais aussi
contributeur en matière économique j'ai
personnellement exprimé la disponibilité
je le serai pour la priorité sur les
technologies médicales
je suis de plus en plus associé avec le
groupe je pense que c'est positif et
nous verrons parce que nous jugerons
aussi sur la manière dont nous pouvons
être entendus ou pas mais nous faisons
ce pari de pouvoir être contributeurs et
je crois que c'est important
juste pour que tous nos téléspectateurs
comprennent dire la majorité actuelle à
sa source et une majorité écologistes
ces jeunes vars et lyon la nouvelle
maire de strasbourg depuis début juillet
c'est une bonne mère jeanne vers ses
gants écoutez elle démarre donc on
jugera un peu plus tard ça fait ça fait
déjà sept mois quelle est celle de son
bilan vous pouvez en tirer
ça fait sept mois je pense que cette
majorité n'a pas encore pris toutes ses
marques et qu'elle doit maintenant
donner la perspective du mandat c'est
important puisque nous allons aborder le
débat budgétaire c'est ce que j'attends
vous avez le sentiment qu'elle était
prête à apprendre dans cette ville dans
un contexte comme celui-là c'est
difficile et je pense que il faut
qu'elle s'appuie sur toutes les forces
qui peuvent permettre à cette ville de
passer le cap de la transition
écologique qu'elle va mener ça veut dire
qu'elle nous écoute pas suffisamment je
pense que elle doit nous écouter
davantage mais en tout cas nous associer
davantage vous sentez pas assez associés
on va parler du siège de strasbourg
siège pareil vous avez été eurodéputés
c'est un sujet qui vous tient à coeur
un an 100 sessions du parlement européen
à strasbourg alors le coc vide a bon dos
qu'est ce qui manque à strasbourg vous
avez été également en charge de la task
force un qui était dont l'objet était de
faire du lobbying auprès des instances
bruxelloises qu'est ce qui manque
et est ce que vous pensez que les
premières actions de la municipalité
sont assez fortes
ce qui manque à strasbourg c'est
certainement d'avoir les fonctionnaires
les services qui permettent de au siège
de véritablement fonctionné le
secrétariat une partie du secrétariat
partie est à luxembourg
mais c'est aussi
organiser le parlement européen commun
ce parc parlement aujourd'hui les
députés sont chez eux pour la plupart
ils ne sont pas à bruxelles à bruxelles
le parlement européen et je dirais la
dernière roue de la charrette
c'est la commission qui a le haut du
pavé c'est le conseil avec les états
membres et le parlement est au fond un
petit peu l'allier mais n'a pas sa place
ici
le parlement européen qu'est ce qu'ils
gagnent ils gagnent affirmer son
indépendance à distance des lobbys ils
gagnent parce qu'il affirme son autorité
c'est lui qui convoque les états membres
les gouvernements ici à strasbourg
mais c'est aussi à strasbourg que le
parlement débat et vote les lois et je
suis aujourd'hui invité sur une chaîne
parlementaire nous avons besoin du
soutien du parlement national
c'est cette légitimité strasbourg là et
là et permet au parlement de l'avoir
parce que ce n'est pas une capitale
d'état nous sommes une ville qui
représente les peuples des citoyens et
c'est ça qui est important une des
failles de strasbourg c'est c'est pas de
ne pas avoir assez travaillé
avec les parlementaires européens alors
il faut une il faut une force yves et
moi je le dis très clairement nous avons
besoin que l'état développe une
stratégie d'abord un réflexe strasbourg
c'est à dire il faut que strasbourg
soient renforcés avec des activités
supplémentaires comme on a pu accueillir
un temps art et comme on a pu accueillir
leur corps comme on a pu accueillir le
système d'information schengen on va
parler de cette polémique qui a été
déclenchée par jean castex quand il est
venu dans la collectivité européenne
d'alsace alors effectivement depuis le
1er janvier il ya un ovni
institutionnels en france et en dans le
grand est avec cette collectivité
européenne d'alsace qui est née de la
fusion des départements du haut-rhin et
du bas-rhin
comment voyez vous cette
cette cette collectivité hybride sachant
que l'eurométropole de strasbourg
mobilise un tiers de l'emploi salarié du
pib en alsace d'abord je voudrais dire
que cette collectivité est né par la
création et dans le cas de la création
du grand test on se souvient de l'échec
du référendum qui posait la question aux
alsaciens d'une seule et unique région
la réponse a été non majoritairement si
la collectivité européenne d'alsace
existe c'est dans ce cadre donc je pense
que ça c'est un premier point
deuxièmement j'ai été quand même
particulièrement surprise et choquée que
le premier ministre en plein débat sur
la loi sur le séparatisme vienne diviser
les alsaciens franchement on a eu à la
cherche animations décision jean castex
et la chercher à diviser sa je pense
qu'il a été peut-être il n'a pas
peut-être compris ce qu'il allait
entraîner mais cette collectivité écrit
dans le cadre de la république
elle a une mission que je saigne celle
de la coopération transfrontalière nom
doit coopérer avec les vosges
tout à l'heure on aura un sénateur
vosgien sur votre plateau il est jeune
il a je dirais sa vie politique devant
lui et bien moi j'aime coopérer avec les
vosges et nous devons coopérer dans
grand test pour l'attractivité pour
l'industrie pour le soutien à l'emploi
l'expression de jean castex s'inscrit
comme dans une région qui a eu du mal et
beaucoup de mal à à renaître est-ce
qu'il faut éventuellement la rue membres
enfin la redessiner cette grande région
alors moi je vais vous dire je crois
qu'aujourd'hui avec la pandémie
on voit où sont les priorités il faut
s'occuper de la santé des français de la
santé physique et de la santé économique
deuxièmement on voit aussi que les
politiques qui se divisent sont en échec
moi j'ai soutenu le dépassement des
partis les organisations partisanes
grâce à trois femmes qui se sont lancés
pour la perspective des prochaines
élections régionales
il faut pouvoir trouver ce qui rassemble
et non pas trouver et choisir ce qui
divise
voilà ce que j'ai regretté dans le
propos de jean castex voilà ce que
j'espère pour les prochaines échéances
c'est un petit message aussi pour le
président de la région qui viendra un
petit peu plus tard je pense qu'il
entend ce message là parce que nous
avons besoin d'une région qui ne
centralise pas comme l'art fait l'état
récemment nous avons deux
une région partenaire et nous avons
besoin de collectivités responsables
dans ce cadre il n'y a pas de problème
avec la collectivité européenne d'alsace
je la considère comme une chance et non
pas comme un boulet à condition qu'elle
sache elle aussi être partenaires merci
beaucoup merci catherine trautmann
[Musique]